time to vanquish that stubborn fat with
the jazzy
they'll help you get your ideal body and
lisa brooks is here to tell us how hey
lisa how's it going
hi good how are you awesome so what is
vanquish me
and how does it work vanquish me
is a radio frequency
equipment that will permanently kill
your fat cells as well as tighten up
your skin
okay so we're destroying fat cells so
the results how long how long do they
last
results are permanent um as long as
we're killing those permanent fat cells
those fat cells won't come back
and the thing is i think i have issues
so many of us have issues with stubborn
fat what are some of the areas
on the body that you guys treat we can
treat
large areas on the body we treat the
stomach we can treat the back we can
also treat
your thighs we also have other smaller
radio frequency devices that we can
handle the arms the face
other smaller areas of the body but the
vanquish me covers
large areas of the body okay walk us
through the process we're looking at
some incredible results before and after
some stomach work done
how long does each treatment work are
they coming in for multiple sessions for
these
you come in once a week it's a session a
series of six
and the results are you actually are
laying down very relaxed
and the session is 45 minutes it can
last a little bit longer if you
incorporate other modalities into it
but it's 45 minutes you're laying down
you're relaxing you can take a nap you
can listen to music
it's very easy and you get the results
of the permanently
killing of your fat cells let me just
recap so i can come see you
i can take a nap and get rid of my
stubborn fat that's what you're telling
us right
yes sign me up thank you lisa let me run
down your special you always have a
special for us
the jazzy wellness the guarantee that
you will lose two inches or more
the same day with their vanquish me
series they're offering 40
off to the first 10 callers so call them
at 702
800 7406 and find them online
at thejazzywellness.com las vegas now
we'll be right back